The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: My spies
tell me that there
was a good mood after the exam.
And it was an exam
that was created
to show the power of intuition
and how you build intuition
based on stuff that
seems kind of ordinary.
And all of a sudden
you have the power
to exercise chemical
insight in ways
which are more
than just textbook
ways of solving differential
equations, memorizing pictures,
and so on.
So this is my purpose, and
at the end of the course
I'm going to try to really
stretch your imagination.
That's the probable schedule.
And so I'm taking more
time with the lecture
on electronic
spectroscopy and dynamics
because this is really
the core of what I do
and what I care about.
And so I don't know what I'm
going to say in this lecture.
I want to spend some time
talking about Zewail's Nobel
Prize work, and certainly
that will be partly on Monday.
Then, intermolecular
interactions
is basically why isn't
everything in the gas phase?
You know everything
isn't in the gas phase,
and this is the first step
towards not being in the gas
phase, kind of important.
And then probably
photochemistry,
which is a little bit more
of electronic spectroscopy
but in a different framework.
Delta functions is
a way of dealing
with complicated potentials
without perturbation theory.
And it's really neat
and it's very abstract,
and it's called the discrete
variable representation,
and it's a very powerful
way of approaching
complicated problems without
having to do a lot of algebra
because the computer
does all of it,
but it does it in a funny way.
And I've been putting
off this lecture
on time-dependent
Hamiltonians for a long time,
and I hope that the last lecture
will be an honest approach
to time-dependent Hamiltonians.
So this is kind
of a motto for me.
Small is a template for large.
If you really
understand everything
a diatomic molecule
can do, you're
prepared to understand most
of what big molecules do.
And so this is sort of
a bottom-up approach.
And what I presented
last time was
sort of a template
for everything
a diatomic molecule can do.
You have a ground state,
and that dissociates
the ground-state atoms.
You have a repulsive state.
Now it's not always
just two states,
but for H2+ or for H2 we sort of
expect this sort of structure.
And then there
are excited states
which are usually less bound
than the ground states.
So they have smaller rotational
constants, larger internuclear
distance.
And if they don't, there's
a good reason for it
which you're supposed
to be able to produce.
Now the repulsive
states often cross
through a bound state, and
this results in what we
call predissociation.
In other words, it happens
before it was intended to.
And it also is an
example for all sorts
of interesting
effects associated
with this curve crossing.
And we'll talk more about that.
And so predissociation
and autoionization,
these are dynamical
effects that occur as you
approach some special limit.
Now this is you're above
the dissociation limit,
so it could happen.
But as far as this data
is concerned, you're not,
and so it happens earlier.
Now here you have ionization.
And below the ionization there's
a whole infinite manifold
of Rydberg states
which look almost
identical to the potential
energy curve for the ion.
And there's all sorts
of stuff that you
can understand about the
electron-ion interaction
by studying Rydberg states.
And that's been, for the
last 20 years, roughly half
of my research.
Now encoded in Rydberg
states is autoionization.
If you have a vibrational
level of a Rydberg state
which lies above the
ionization limit, well,
then it can ionize, and
that's interesting too.
So this is a very quick summary
of what I talked about before,
and I want to add to that.
So in order for a
transition to occur,
you either need a permanent
dipole moment, a dipole moment
derivative with respect to
the displacement coordinate,
or an electronic transition.
So this is the rule.
This is what you need for a
pure rotation transition which
is looked at in the microwave.
This is what you need for
a vibrational transition.
The dipole moment has to
depend on displacement
from equilibrium for
one of the coordinates.
If it's a diatomic,
there's only one.
If it's a polyatomic,
there's 3n minus 6.
And so these two things
are very important.
And then the electronic
transition moment,
you can always have
transitions where
you promote an electron
from the ground state
to an excited state.
But since the operator is
a one-electron operator,
the strong transitions
are a very small subset
of all the possible ones.
And one of the important
things for dealing
with electronic transitions is
the Franck-Condon principle.
The Franck-Condon
principle is basically
a restatement of the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation
that the electrons move
fast, nuclei move slowly.
And as a result, delta R
equals 0, delta P equals 0.
Now I'm using
capital letters just
to mean all of the coordinates.
And this is what we call
a vertical transition.
And delta P equals 0
is stationary phase.
Now I like stationary phase.
You have integrals of
oscillating functions,
and you're integrating
usually over all space.
But the integral accumulates
to its final value
in a very small region of
space, and that region of space
corresponds to where the momenta
on the upper and lower states,
or whatever you're
looking at, where
the momentum are the same.
And this enables you to use
classical insights because
instead of having quantum
mechanics where you're thinking
about wave functions
and thinking like I've
got an integral to do and
I can't say anything simple
about it, but if you know
that the integral accumulates
in a particular geometry,
then you can even estimate it.
You know what determines
how big that integral is.
And this is almost
always neglected
in talking about the
Franck-Condon principle,
but it's a very important
part, especially for me,
because I want to find
out simple things,
and the simple things are always
in simple places in state space
or in coordinate space.
And then there's the
Franck-Condon factor.
The Franck-Condon factor
is something you calculate.
If you know the potential or
you have a reasonable estimate
of the shape of a
potential, you can
calculate all the
vibrational wave functions
in that potential.
Not a big deal.
I haven't taught
you how to do it.
I will talk about it in
573, but that's next year,
and that's a different
life for most of you.
But you can calculate the
vibrational wave functions.
And the Franck-Condon
factor is the square
of the overlap between
the vibrational wave
function for the initial
state and the final state.
So principle, factor,
big difference.
We want ideas.
Franck-Condon factors
are numerical.
We want to know what's behind
the Franck-Condon factors,
and the Franck-Condon
principle and stationary phase
is what's behind it.
And so you're now
charged with being
able to understand
everything that
happens in electronic
transitions guided by this very
important principle, which
is really relegated only
to calculating Franck-Condon
factors, which is just
something you do as opposed
to something you think about.
So that was kind of a summary
of what we did last time.
So we can have an
electronic band system.
So that's a transition
between two electronic states,
and these electronic states
have vibrational levels,
and the vibrational levels
have rotation levels.
And so it depends
on how deep you
want to go into understanding
electronic transitions
but what are the questions
we want to answer?
When we record a spectrum,
we record a spectrum
not just to publish a paper
or to fulfill an assignment
but to ask questions, and
so what do we want to know?
And there's how questions
and why questions.
How is a particular
excited state
different from the ground state?
This means excited state.
This means ground state.
Spectroscopists
use that notation.
People who don't know
anything about spectroscopy
use whatever notation they feel
like, and that's really stupid.
But anyway, that's a
different sort of thing.
And so how are states different?
Well, they have different
equilibrium geometries.
They have different
vibrational frequencies.
They have different energies.
It's a transition between states
pretty far apart in energy.
There's permanent dipole moment.
There's transition
dipole moments.
There's radiative lifetimes.
There's all sorts of things
that are distinct from one
electronic state to another.
And so this is how they're
different, but then why?
This is much more interesting,
but you do this in order
to start asking why.
And so you already have
qualitative electronic
structure stuff like LCAO, MO.
Now you could calculate
things really accurately,
but you wouldn't be
using your brain,
and this is MIT for God's sake.
You do want to use your brain
to explain why one state is
different from
another, and there's
all sorts of
qualitative theories
that are your guide or your
framework for doing this.
And LCAO-MO, Huckel
theory, these
are the kinds of things
that you can use.
And we also have ideas
about orbitals, bonding.
So we have orbitals that
are bonding, nonbinding,
antibonding, and we
know this by drawing
a molecular orbital diagram.
And we know the
properties of what
happens when you have bonding
and antibonding orbitals.
We have hybridization.
So a tremendous amount is gained
by asking for a carbon atom,
and for many other atoms,
what is the spn hybridization?
We make a special
set of orbitals
which focus on the
structure around each atom.
And again, you can be guided by
what you know from the spectrum
or what you know from
simple rules to saying, OK,
if we have this
hybridization, there
is a certain geometry
around that atom.
Or if we have that
geometry or if it's
constrained to
have that geometry,
it will have this hybridization.
And we haven't talked
about this very much,
but it's a very important part
of understanding chemistry.
And then we have these
things where we--
so we look at
families of molecules
where you have the same
number of electrons.
And that was on the exam,
and it's really beautiful
how you can say,
OK, even though we
have the same
number of electrons,
if we change the difference
in ionization energy
between the two atoms,
terrible things happen
or wonderful, beautiful
things happen.
It depends on what you like.
And homologous is just the same
number of valence electrons
but from different rows
of the periodic table,
and you had that
on the exam too.
These are the tricks we use.
And then there's dynamics.
And some people might say we
study structure so that we
can understand dynamics.
I'm not quite there yet,
but dynamics is interesting
because it's harder
than structure.
You have a static structure.
The spectrum is telling
you what that is.
But it's also
telling you, if you
look at it the right way,
what the molecule can
do when it gets excited.
And I frequently start my talks
with two slides, one called
molecules at play where the
molecules are in the ground
state, and they're not doing
anything interesting, and then
molecules at work where
molecules are highly excited
and doing what they're
supposed to do.
And our job is really
not to understand play.
Let them do what
they want, but we'd
like to understand
when they're working
and how do we work with them?
So dynamics is really
that kind of a question.
There's all sorts of
kinds of dynamics.
There's dissociation.
There's ionization.
There's Born-Oppenheimer
breakdown.
And you probably notice these
letters, and that's what I do.
I'm known for being a specialist
in Born-Oppenheimer breakdown.
It appears in many
different ways.
And so there's predissociation.
There's autoionization.
There's avoided crossings.
And there's adiabtic
versus diabatic.
So these two things are
really different sides
of the same coin.
Suppose you have two
potential curves that cross.
Well, this is what we think
about as chemists where
a potential curve
corresponds to following
the energy without really
significantly changing
the electronic structure.
And so these crossing curves
are what we call diabatic.
But if you're a quantum
chemistry, what you would do
is you would calculate
the adiabatic curves,
and they would look like that.
They don't cross.
And so we have two
ways of looking
at the interaction between
two electronic states,
the adiabatic one
and the diabatic one,
and we use whichever
one is simpler
for the particular case.
And at some point
later in this lecture
I hope to talk about a
thing called Landau-Zener.
And it basically is
suppose you're driving
at night on a very curvy road.
And you're mostly awake,
but you're driving too fast.
And so if you have a
situation like this
where there's a sharp curve,
and maybe if you're lucky
there is another sharp curve
on another road somewhere
over here.
You're going too fast.
You're going to go off
the road, and maybe you'll
end up on this other road or
you'll end up hitting a tree.
So if you're going fast, you're
going to jump off the curve.
That's diabatic.
And that's the point of
view we take as chemists.
And if you're going
really slowly,
you'll stay on the road.
You won't even remember
this intersection
because you didn't die at it.
And that's adiabatic.
And depending on the
gap and the curvature
for a particular
situation, the molecule
knows how to either
do this or do that.
And it's not fatal
for the molecule,
but if the molecule is going
through a curve-crossing region
fast, it's going
to jump the gap.
And that's one of the things
that Zewail looked at.
If you can start
a system at energy
high above the energy
where the curves cross,
you're going
through really fast.
If you excite it really close
to the energy of the curve
crossing, you're
going through slowly.
And so by changing
the conditions,
you can understand
what's going to happen.
This is really
powerful for insight.
What I'm trying to
convey is that there
are very simple pictures
to describe really
complicated-looking things.
And sometimes the data on
these complicated things
are very hard to either
obtain or to interpret
because it looks--
well, often it looks--
what would people say?
It looks statistical.
Now statistical is
really a cop out.
It says, I don't understand
what's going on here,
and so I'll approach it
as if there isn't any law.
And we just count the
density of states,
and we'd use simple formulas.
And the shameful thing is
that that usually works,
but it only works so far.
It doesn't lead to insight.
It just leads to
a representation,
and our job is to understand,
not just to represent.
So back to this question
of electronic transitions
and the Franck-Condon principle.
So if we have a transition
between two potential curves
that have the same
geometry, we get a delta v
equals 0 propensity rule.
It has good and bad sides.
One is the spectrum gets to
be really simple because you
only see transitions between
the same vibrational quantum
upstairs and downstairs.
And this is true for polyatomic
and diatomics as well.
You get a simple spectrum
and you say, oh crap, I
can go home early.
But you don't know anything
about other vibrational levels,
and if you're starting
in the zero vibrational
level of the ground
state, well, you only
know about the zero vibrational
level of the excited
state if the potential
cures are the same,
and there's all sorts
of stuff you don't know.
And if you're doing
emission, well, maybe
in an emission spectrum you
excite more vibrational levels.
But what's going to happen is
if they're all have the same--
if the potential
curves are the same,
well, then all the
vibrational transitions
are going to be on top of
each other in emission,
and you might as well
not have bothered.
It's just a horrible situation.
So delta v equals 0 depends
on what your point of view is.
If you want to understand
things, this is bad.
And then you can have
transitions between states
which have different
shapes or displaced,
and the Franck-Condon
calculation
tells you how this works.
But here you have
delta v equals many.
But now for a
polyatomic molecule
where you have n atoms, you
have 3n minus 6 normal modes.
And some of them are going to
be like this, and some of them
are going to be like this.
And that's good and bad
because what it's saying is,
yeah, you could have had a
really complicated spectrum
because there's so
many vibrational--
I mean, for example, benzene
has 30 vibrational levels, 30
vibrational modes--
not 1 but 30, and some of them
have relatively low frequency.
And benzene for most of
you is a simple molecule.
For me, it's really
just beyond complex.
And what happens when you have
a lot of vibrational levels
is the vibrational density
states gets very high, very
fast, so high that it's
hopeless to be able to resolve
the individual eigenstates.
When that happens, frequency
domain spectroscopy
stops being so useful because
a lot of the key details
are hidden.
So if it's not frequency domain,
it wants to be time domain,
and you can ask
really good questions
using time-domain
techniques, which
is what I'm going to talk about
when I spend some time with Mr.
Zewail.
So you're going to have
certain normal modes which
are what we call Franck-Condon
dark because they don't
contribute to the spectrum.
You only see delta
v of 0 for modes.
And the ones that lead
to a change in geometry
or a change in bond structure,
those are the ones you see.
Those are the
Franck-Condon bright ones,
and they're also much more
interesting because why
did the geometry change?
What part of the
molecule was responsible
for the geometry change?
This is what
chemists want to ask.
So that's the framework.
Now, I've spent the last
30 years of my life looking
at the acetylene molecule.
Acetylene, for me, it's
as big as I want to get,
but for most of you that's
really, really small.
And acetylene has
ground state which
we can denote by a zero
here, s0, lowest singlet.
If we had a different
number of electrons
we might say-- if we had
an odd number of electrons,
the lowest state
would be D0 or T0
if it had a triplet
ground state like oxygen.
The notation is simple.
But we also use--
spectroscopists use notation
where we use a Roman capital
letter with a tilde over
it for polyatomic molecules
and not for diatomics,
and the electronic state,
the ground state is this.
And have to be careful
because the notation
that organic chemists would
use for acetylene is just this.
And my point is I want to talk
about where the hydrogens are.
And so this is kind
of a cheat because it
sounds like I put a
hydrogen on a butene
because you have carbon
here, these bonds.
OK, you know the [INAUDIBLE].
And then there's an excited
state which we could call S1.
And the excited state
looks like this.
It's trans bent.
This has a triple bond.
This has a double bond.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: What?
AUDIENCE: There's
also [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT FIELD: Yes, there's a--
you know about this paper here.
But the lowest equilibrium
geometry for the excited state
is trans bent.
You can have this
structure too, and we
have looked at the
isomerization between these two,
and how did we do that?
How did we characterize
the transition state
for the isomerization?
This is 20, 30 person years of
work getting to the transition
state, and it led to
a paper in Science,
my first in 40 years of trying.
And so this is a
molecule I really
like because there
are four modes which
are Franck-Condon dark and two
that are Franck-Condon bright.
And we can do all sorts
of really neat things.
So in the ground state at
high vibrational excitation,
what do we expect?
Well, one thing is
nothing special.
Well, the molecule could just
go on doing nothing interesting,
having four modes which are
Franck-Condon dark and two
modes that are
Franck-Condon bright.
It will remain boring.
And another would be just
increasing complexity
because there can be
anharmonic interactions
between different normal modes.
And so when that starts to
happen people start to say,
let me out of here.
It gets complicated, and
everything gets destroyed,
and the spectrum just
becomes uninterpretable,
which is wrong.
And then there is chaos
which is another way--
or quantum chaos--
which is another way
of waving your hands and
saying it's statistical.
And we know my
opinion about that
because bonds are really
sacred in chemistry
and if there are bonds, there
isn't bag of atoms behavior.
And then there's other
possibility, isomerization.
So this guy at high exaltation
can go to that vinylidene.
And I spent a hundred person
years chasing after this.
So there is a very
shallow vinylidene well,
and how is this kind
of isomerization
encoded in the spectrum?
So in order to have a chance of
understanding about vinylidene
or things that
happen in the ground
state at very high excitation,
I invented a fairly important
method for looking at
high vibrational levels.
It's called stimulated
emission pumping,
and it looks like this.
So we have two--
now this initially
was demonstrated
on a diatomic molecule,
but its true importance
is for something like acetylene.
So what happens is you can
excite to this distorted
molecule from the ground state,
and some vibrational levels
are accessible because you
have a little bit of room
between two turning points.
So you can excite a
few vibrational levels
by vertical transitions.
But the important thing is
that each vibrational level
has an inner turning point,
which is how you access it,
and an outer turning point,
which enables you to do--
so this is called the pump,
and this is called the dump.
Now I'm not sure whether
I came up with pump
and dump before it was
talked about on Wall Street,
but it was a very apt name for
stimulated emission pumping.
And so what we can
do then is to access
very high vibrational levels
in the electronic ground state
by pump and dump.
And the way we detect it
is we get fluorescence
from this level.
And when we hit the
dump transition,
the fluorescences
decrease in intensity.
And we can do a
very significant map
of what's going on at high
excitation in the ground state.
And when I invented SEP, I
believed in quantum chaos.
So I expected as we went
up higher and higher
we would see breaking of
all the usual patterns.
And I even wrote
a paper saying we
had seen quantum chaos
when we excited to very
high vibrational levels.
And the reasoning for
that is complicated,
but the reasoning
was correct except it
didn't apply to chaos.
It just applied to the spectrum
getting complicated, really
complicated.
So what I really
wanted to be able to do
was to be able to somehow
sample this transition state.
And that experiment
in its initial form
was doomed to fail because
this transition state involves
a local bend.
In other words, acetylene
has normal modes, suspend,
trans bend, CH
symmetric stretch,
CH antisymmetric
stretch, and CC stretch.
And this coordinate
is mostly just that,
a large-amplitude local band.
And so when I started
this, I didn't
know that local
bands would magically
emerge from the spectrum,
but they do and we saw them,
and that led to a
lot of good stuff.
I should mention that I
got tenure at MIT because
of stimulated emission pumping.
That was a long time ago.
So we had not seen the
isomerization in the ground
state because we
couldn't get high enough
because Franck-Condon
factors prevented us
from getting high enough.
And the spectrum also
gets complicated,
and there's all sorts of
reasons why it didn't work.
But as far as the cis-trans
isomerization in the excited
state, we killed
that, and we killed
that because we saw
new patterns emerge,
and that was more robust
than normal modes.
And then we saw those
new patterns break,
and the breaking is
due to isomerization.
And we worked out the
theory, and that's
what the Science
paper was all about.
So now, gas phase
versus condensed phase.
People who work in
the gas phase don't
talk to people who work in
the condensed phase and vice
versa because the spectra
are profoundly different.
So we have a ground state and
we have some excited state.
And whether it's a
diatomic molecule
or a polyatomic molecule,
it doesn't matter that much.
So what we have in the
absorption spectrum
is vertical transitions to
a few vibrational levels,
depending on the
difference in geometry.
And in the condensed
phase, instead
of staying in the vibrational
level we populated,
there is rapid
transfer of energy
from the molecule
into its surroundings,
and you end up in v equals
0 of the excited state.
And then the spectrum is
to a few vibrational levels
of the ground state.
And so you get something
that looks like this.
This is the sort
of classic diagram
for absorption versus
emission spectra
of a polyatomic molecule.
So this is emission.
This is absorption.
And frequency is on the right.
So what happens is in the
absorption spectrum you observe
transitions to
higher vibrational
levels-- to several
vibrational levels,
v prime equals 0 and higher.
And so those are to the
blue of the band origin.
And in emission, you
get emission only from v
equals 0 in the excited
state, and that's
to the red of the origin.
And so you get this classic
double-hump picture.
And there's all sorts
of vibrational levels
that are not resolved,
and this is basically
the kind of crappy
spectrum you get
when you look at a big molecule
in the condensed phase.
And so it's telling
you frequency domain
for this sort of thing
is the wrong approach
because there's
nothing much here.
So this thing, the expectation
value, the Hamiltonian
for the molecule as opposed
to the overall system
is time dependent.
We're used to the Hamiltonian
being time independent.
There can be
dynamics because you
excite a coherent
superposition of states.
So for condensed-phase systems,
the Hamiltonian or energy
is not conserved
in the molecule.
But of course
thermodynamics says
if you have an isolated
system it's conserved.
That's irrelevant
because we always
want to look at something more
interesting than a bulk sample.
Now I want to talk
about dynamics
that is more subtle
than the naive stuff--
so subtle dynamics.
Well, let's have no collisions.
Well, we can do that
in the gas phase
if the pressure's low enough.
No breaking of molecules.
So if there is no
predissociation or
autoionization--
so we can restrict ourselves
to a low enough energy
that things don't break.
Now this is subtle.
Molecules will fluoresce, and
populations in excited states
will decay.
And as a rule, the
fluorescence lifetime,
if it's truly only fluorescence
and not other dynamics,
the lifetime is longer
than 10 nanoseconds.
So if we're looking at times
shorter than 10 nanoseconds
we can say there's
no fluorescence.
We're going to ignore that.
That's OK because there
still can be dynamics.
So simplest case,
two-level quantum beats,
and you know about
quantum beats.
You've already looked at
them in various problems.
And so you have a system
where you have a ground state
and you have two excited states,
and one of them is bright
and one of them is
dark with respect
to transitions from this state.
But there is an
interaction between them,
and so they're mixed character
and with a short pulse.
You prepare a
coherent superposition
of two eigenstates.
The intensity of
the fluorescence
oscillates, and it isolates
at the frequency difference
of these two levels.
And the modulation depth
of the fluorescence
tells you something about
what is the coupling matrix
element between these two
states relative to the energy
difference between them?
So there's a lot of
information in there,
and so this is something
that can happen faster
than the spontaneous
fluorescence.
One is observing it in the
spontaneous fluorescence,
but the whole point is you're
looking at some dynamics that
is encoded in eigenstates.
And that's one of my mottos.
We know how to write
all the theory for this.
We have something
that looks broad,
but in reality it's a
whole bunch of eigenstates.
And the pattern of
these eigenstates
is telling you what
the dynamics is.
Now normally we
think of dynamics
as the width of something.
And this collection of
eigenstates behaving
in some coherent
way has a width,
but that's only the beginning.
What was the thing that gave
intensity to these eigenstates?
What was the zero-order
state, and what
was the coupling matrix element
between the bright state
and the dark state, and what
are the rules for these?
And so if you can resolve
these eigenstates,
you learn about much more
detailed picture of dynamics
than just saying, well,
dynamics is a width.
If you're below the energy
where molecules can break,
there is no width.
But if you do a
crappy experiment,
you don't resolve stuff
and it looks broad.
Now, sometimes the
molecule sets the standard
for what's a real experiment
by having its density of states
so large you couldn't resolve
it even if you had the best
experiment in the world.
But there's still the idea
that inside this broad thing
there is some
interpretable dynamics.
That's my goal.
Well, one kind of
interpretable dynamics
is, OK, so you have some excited
state and some ground state,
and there's a range
of vibrational levels
that you can excite.
And if you have a
short pulse, you
make a coherent
superposition of all
of those vibrational levels.
And then what you have is
some wave packet which has got
an energy, sort of
the average of these.
And the wave packet starts
out at a turning point
because you started out with
essentially zero momentum.
And the wave packet moves,
and it goes back and forth
and back and forth.
And it's telling you what
the vibrational frequency
of that mode is.
And so you can then observe the
fluorescence from this evolving
wave packet, or you can monitor
this evolving wave packet
either by looking
at fluorescence back
to where you started.
And so when it's
over here, it can't
fluoresce to where you started.
When it's over here where
it was born, it can.
And so the fluorescence
is going to be doing
a kind of quantum beating.
You could also use some kind
of pump-probe experiment
where you say, I'm going
to look at the wave packet
when it's here because
I have a transition
to another electronic state.
And so the vertical
excitation is at that energy,
and so I wait for the wave
packet to get to a point.
And so you have a
periodic motion.
And you have dephasing because
this wave packet is built out
of vibrational levels
which are not harmonic so
that there is some dispersion
of the vibrational frequencies
around the average.
As a result, that causes
this thing to dephase.
And its dephasing time
could look like a width,
but it's actually a
particular mechanism.
And then there are other
things that can happen,
and I love this.
So we've got a few minutes.
So suppose we have two
electronic states that
are crossing, and you're
starting out in this level.
You made a wave packet.
So this is going back
and forth, and every half
oscillation it goes through
this critical region.
What's that region?
What's special
about that region?
Come on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
ROBERT FIELD: Not if
this is a bounce state.
That's a good try.
That is, in fact, if this
were a repulsive state,
then predissociation
would occur when
it cross through the region.
This is the stationary
phase region.
This is where the momentum
on the two potential curves
is the same.
And so the molecule can make up
its mind which potential curve
it wants to leave on because
there's no impulse that causes
a change in its
momentum, and it just
makes a decision which one.
And so when that happens, if
you're following the dynamics,
you have a series of beats.
And I'm just sketching
them as a stick,
but really, they have width.
And then at some
later type you start
seeing a new family
of oscillations
because now you've got some
amplitude on this other state,
and it has a
different frequency.
But the important thing--
and I should stop here--
is that the only
time the molecule
has to change its
mind between one state
and another is
when it's crossing
through this stationary
phase region.
So it's a complicated
thing, but it's
isolating a particular region
where the curves cross.
And where the curves
cross, instead
of having crossing
curves, you could
have something like this
and something like that.
Now we're back to Mr.
Landau and Mr. Zener.
And so if there's a
curve crossing, depending
on how far above
the curve crossing,
it tells you how fast
you're going through it.
See, there's all sorts
of wonderful stuff here,
which is not the
trivial dynamics that--
this is the only way you get
broadening is the molecule
breaks.
And the fluorescence
is usually so slow--
10 nanoseconds is slow--
that you don't see any
broadening because 10
nanoseconds corresponds to
a pretty high resolution,
and most people aren't looking
at that kind of resolution.
And so we have
quantum beats which
then can show beautiful
dynamics in a way
that if you're prepared to
build a model and to say, well,
we could have this
case and this case--
this is the chemists' case.
We have quantum chemists' case--
you can interpret everything.
This is very much related
to what Mr. Zewail does.
And I will spend a
significant amount of time
on Monday talking about
the Zewail experiments
and how the whole point
of his experiments
are not just saying, OK,
I excite the molecule
and it breaks.
It breaks in this much time.
Well, that's a useful
question, but what
did it do before it broke?
One particular bond breaks,
but what about the motions
of the other bonds?
Or maybe you're
talking about breaking
in a particular normal mode.
Does the molecule arrange
itself to be broken?
Or once it's excited
it goes downhill
to the graveyard in
a particular path,
but there are
wonderful things you
can do by asking, what is the
mechanism by which the molecule
breaks?
And by varying how you
excite the molecule,
you're looking at different
aspects of that mechanism.
Now Zewail sold this
really hard, and it worked.
And so I'll leave
that for Monday.